hello
everyone thank you for joining this
session
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for today's
first session on bioinformatics
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for today's first session on
bioinformatics and computational biology
today we will discuss about
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for today's first session on
bioinformatics and computational biology
today we would be starting with an
overview of the tools and the resources
for the program
the courses projects and the data sets
and also talk about the server access
we would discuss about the knowledge
driven versus data driven discovery
examples
and also talk about the applications of
bioinformatics in agriculture
neuroscience cancer
biology immunology defense
and healthcare expectations
my name is sunali kari and i would want
to start
to introducing our company vision and
team that stands behind
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all
for today's first session on
bioinformatics and computational biology
today we will be talking about the
overview of the tools and the resources
for this program
the courses projects and the data sets
you have to go
through and also talk about the access
for the tbi
info server we will discuss about
knowledge driven versus data driven
discovery examples
and also discuss the applications of
bioinformatics in
agriculture neuroscience cancer biology
immunology defense and health care
expectations
my name is sunali khari and i would want
to start by introducing our company
vision and team that stands behind the
various resources
and training programs that we will go
over today
omixlogic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed in collaboration between pine
biotech
and the topper bioinformatics research
center at the university of haifa
the company was started as a result of
technology transfer from the center
which was founded by dr alfred tauber
and dr leonid brotzky
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background has extensive
expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support of many
research projects
and initiatives that support data
science training and applications in
medicine
dr yunit brodsky is the director of the
dropper bioinformatics resource center
at the university of haifa and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum
and support research projects using our
omixlogic project based curriculum
over the past several years we had the
privilege of working with a number of
organizations
developing a training program for
research-oriented students faculty and
democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students and
faculty around the world
using the cutting edge or mixed logic
resources we bring a unique opportunity
to learn computational biology and apply
data science techniques by working with
expert bioinformaticians
before we go through the topics that
will be covered in the program
as a community manager i interact with
many participants who
are entrusted to know if they are
eligible for this training program
let me explain that so this program is a
great fit for students
who are interested in learning about the
ongoing life science research
and to develop skill sets to analyze
genetic and clinical
data this program is also a great fit
for researchers who are keen to apply
computational biology tools
to their research projects and faculty
who are working on research projects and
proposals
and have a keen interest in teaching
bioinformatics
the industry-driven omixlogic curriculum
helps biologists and clinicians working
with
industry and research labs to analyze
their own data
and take decisions based on the analysis
this program is available through our
collaborators and mentors in the us
canada india sri lanka and for the
students and researchers in
africa we are looking forward to your
participation in the program please find
the link of registration to the program
in the
in the description box for the video
thank you